ونحيكم مشاهدينا من جديد اصدرت قناه ايران
انترناشونال بيانا دانت فيه تهديد الحرس
ثور الايراني لصحافي القناه ومراسلها
وودعت المجتمع الدولي والمنظمات الحقوقيه
الى التضامن معها والى ادارت هذه
الممارسات من قبل النظام الايراني وكانت
قد اصدرت قبل اسبوعين بيانا حذرت فيه من
تهديدات مصدرها نظام الايراني تلقاها
العاملون في القناه داخل بريطانيا وذكر
بيان ايران انترناشونال انها شبكه اخباريه
مستقله باللغه الفارسيه وما قارها
بريطانيا وانها تشعر بالصدمه والقلق بشان
تهديدات الموثقه التي تلقاها صحفيوها من
الحرس الثوري الايراني واضاف البيان ان
اثنين من صحافيين القناه الايرانيين
البريطانيين ابلغان بتزايد التهديدات
ضدهما في الايام الاخيره وانا شرطه
العاصمه البريطانيه لندن اخترت كل
الصحفيين او كلاصيين صحفيين الاثنين رسميا
بان تهديدات بشكل خطرا وشيكا وكبيرا على
حياتهما وحياه عائليهما كما تم ابلكم
موظفين اخرين بتهديدات المنفصله من قبل
شرطه العاصمه كما كان وزير الاستخبارات
الايرانيه اسمع الخطيب قد وصل القوات
الايرانيه غير المغليه للنظام بالارهابيه
متهما اياها بالتسبب في اثاره الراي العام
والاحتجاجات ومطالبا بالتخلص منها
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيفتنا من لندن سحر
بيت مشعل صحفيه في قناه ايراني انتر
ناشونال اهلا بك معنا سحر الى هذه الحلقه
من بانوراما ولمناقشه هذا الملف هناك من
زملائك من تحدثوا عن تهديدات الحقيقيه
ترده من الحرس الثوري تهدد حتى حياتهم كيف
ذلك
البريطانيه استدعت اثنين من زملاء
الصحفيين عاملين في قناه ايرانيه
على حياتهم واثارهم على وشك التنفي
طبعا صحتهم باخذ الاحتياطات اللازمه احب
ان نبذه عن قناه
حوالي اكثر من خمسه سنين
[موسيقى]
كوكب من الصحفيين اسماء اللامعه هم همم
لهم تاريخ طويل في في الصحافه كانوا قبل
يعني قبل كانوا يشترون في داخل ايران ولكن
بعد
الاحداث التي حصلت همم
2009 خرجوا كثير منهم بسبب الاعتقالات
طبعا المشكله الحين يعني اكثر نتحدث عنها
هي وجود تهديدات على الاراضي البريطانيه
التي لم على صحفيين الايرانيين هنا همم
كان لها مواقف كثيره همم يعني مواقف
الحكومه البريطانيه ومنها همم
النواب طرحه في البرلمان كافيه الرجاء هذه
التصرفات التي من قبل
حتى قبل ان نتقدم في الحوار حتى افهم منك
يا اكثر يعني تتحدثين عن ان هناك معلومات
وصلت لبعض الزملاء لديكم في ايران
انترناشونال مفادها بان ايران قادره ان
تستهدفهم على الاراضي البريطانيه
نعم صحيح وطبعا احنا مو اول مره الي احنا
نتلقي التهديدات من الصحفيين او العاملين
في ايران الانترنت
حوالي 5 سنين نحن معك خاصه مع اكيد تغطيه
اييي الاحداث التي الاحتجاجات في ايران
يعني في
اتصلنا كثير من التهديدات حتى في حتى على
اسرنا اللي موجودين داخل ايران لكن يمكن
هالمره اكثر كان لها صدى والسبب ان الشرطه
نفسها تدخلت ووصل لكم المعلومات بوجوده
كان في عمليه ممكن اغتيال يعني تستهدف
حياه الصحفيين الايرانيين في في بريطانيا
نعم وهذا كله طبعا
هو لا شيء يبرر عمليات الاغتيال ولكن على
الاقل اذا اخذنا مثلا التمديدات الايرانيه
رسميه مما اا ينشره صحفي ايران
انترناشونال همم ما المزعج في عملكم يعني
ما هل تغلطون هل تبالغون هل تنشرون
الحقيقه همم ما الذي يحدث ما سبب
نحن قناه مستقله بدون تحيز الناس
ظهر الواقع والاحداث التي تجري في ايران
وهذا ما لمسه ال- ال- الناس في داخل ايران
وهذا وبكل ثقه اقدر اقول ان اذا اام
لها مكانه خاصه وشعبيه خاصه في داخل ايران
وكذلك وكذلك تواصل الناس
لايصاصه صوتي هم عن طريق ارسال الصور
ارسال الفيديوهات او حتى فورت نايت
ريبورتات كثيره تكشف الحقائق عن عن الفساد
اللي موجود في في في بعض في بعض ال- ال-
في بعض المسؤولين الايرانيين الكبار اللي
موجودين همم كل عن طريق تواصل الناس
وفقتهم ثقتهم في ايران فرناشونال وهذا
الشيء الملموس وكل هذا همم بسبب يعني
جهودنا جهودنا المهنيه
ومحاولاتنا لاث وجود استغلاليه في الاخبار
التي هل لديكم احساس سحر بانكم تؤثرون في
هذه الاحتجاجات تؤثرون مش بمعنى تغالطون
ولكن تؤثرون بمعنى انكم تطرحون حقيقه ما
يحدث فيحدث هناك وعيد همم في داخل
الايراني وتقومون بنشر اا دقيق لما يحدث
ايران او نظام الايراني
يخاف من ذلك
بصراحه
الوعي والادراك السياسي
للايرانيين هو هو همم ليس ليس فقط مديون
للوسائل للعام القدره الادراكيه للسياسه
الموجوده هم حتى في في همم في الشباب اللي
موجودين او حتى صغار بالسن وهذا مشهود في
عدد قتله ال- ال- الاحداث الاخيره في
الشهرين الاخيره هو ما ما يشهد همم
يدل على هذا الموضوع لكن حاليا همم نحن لا
نؤثر نحن بس نوصل الكلمه والاخبار الموثقه
واصاله الحقيقه للناس اكثر نعم ولكن حاليا
حتى مع قطع الانترنت ملك ان الناس قاعده
تحاول تتواصل
سحر تماما توقيت الحلقه ساعدته بمشارتك
معنا سحر بيت مشعل صحفيه في قناه ايران
ايه تمام التوقيت الحلقه سحر اراك الحلقه
الاخرى السلام عليكم